david is a uh well he's a trained lawyer
he doesn't practice law anymore but that
was his background and in the last cast
we talked a lot about the importance of
having multiple passports being able to
maneuver you know and move from country
to country one of the things that he
made very clear during the last cast is
that
you don't actually own your passport so
i mean look we've seen what happened in
the last year a couple years anyway with
the beer bug
and the overreach of power and control
from government it's it it still exists
today in canada i mean i'm a pure blood
so i can't travel outside of the country
still on federal airlines um i could
drive across the border so i'm going to
be dealing with that a little bit but um
yeah like they have the right to say you
know what sir uh mr cooper we're gonna
take away your passport because we don't
for whatever reason they don't even have
to tell you probably
um and you're not able to fly you know
without a passport so one of the
arguments that david made the last time
we were talking and he was kind of like
a high-value client as an example i
think he said he had a um
uh
a kuwaiti uh
client of his that was
trying to get funds
um or travel it was it was tied into uh
finance and it was a large sum of money
that was tied up
and because the government in the
country that he had resided in
um put a limitation on travel and
movement of funds
he put himself in a pretty precarious
predicament where he had pretty much
like 95 percent of his cash locked up
so we made the argument in that last
cast you guys can go back and watch that
i i wanted to talk to david a little bit
more hopefully he'll still show up um if
he gets the email and uh hops in but
the thing that i wanted to hit on with
this one
is this uh publication that he put out
on his website at les browns and
associates the title is is principal
residence capital gains exemption under
threat in canada so if you're not
familiar
in most places in the world still um you
can buy a house live in it when you sell
it whatever capital gains that you make
off it are completely tax free
it's
i think probably one of the last tax
free havens with the exception of
uh a tfsa which stands for tax-free
savings account here in canada which
doesn't allow you to set aside much i
think it's maximum about 80 90 000
uh to this um at the time of this
recording right now but they add an
extra like five grand a year to it sort
of thing
um there's no real tax-free savings
vessels and for the most part most
people that retire here in canada aren't
retiring
on
their pensions or any retirement savings
plans that they've set aside it's
generally the value the appreciated
value in their home
and uh he uses an example in here which
i think is
fairly accurate so i'm just going to
kind of go through this and i'll read it
out to you
um at pres sorry at present your primary
residence may secure you a comfortable
retirement for canadian taxpayers and
again this is not limited to canada i
mean if you listen closely to what your
legislators and policy makers talk about
in parliament when it comes to raising
tax revenue or creating tax revenue for
the country
if you've been asleep the last couple
years
let me remind you that the money supply
in the united states has doubled
in the course of two years
over its entire lifetime okay so they've
printed more money than any other time
in history vermont for for stimulus to
send out checks to uh people you know
when they took away their jobs and shut
down businesses and they had to give the
money to pay uh rent
there was a lot
a ton of money that was printed in the
last couple years and you can't print
money and create debt without paying for
it and they generally pay um for
you know revenue that needs to generate
to spend on
you know keeping people home as an
example like the beer bug if there's a
pandemic
i use that term loosely obviously
um
or if they have to uh you know stimulate
the economy
economy with infrastructure and stuff
like that so they have to create tax
revenue and one of the best places they
haven't tapped into yet that would
generate a ton of tax revenue for them
is taxing capital gains on a principal
residence which they don't do right now
anyway so let me read this to you again
um taxpayers the primary residence is
their single largest asset with recent
price explosions it is now an asset with
a large amount of unrealized capital
gains appreciation as of 2022 the
average canadian household net worth is
nearing 1 million
of the capital gains from any potential
sale for the canadian government the
inability to tax principal resident
gains therefore means millions of lost
potential tax revenue
they already taxes everywhere
everywhere you know you buy gas you
pay yourself you take an income from an
employer
you buy any goods or service you're
paying taxes on it you're paying taxes
when you invest money outside of your
retirement savings everything you do
they bend you over and they tax you with
the exception of your principal
residence which values by the way have
exploded over the last few years in
canada uh to give you an example
um i bought my house this one here
um
2011 or so so around 10 years now
and it's more than doubled in value i'd
probably say yeah it's it's definitely
more than doubled in value um which
is a rate of return that you're not
going to get anywhere else with the
exception of um if you're an early
adopter of something like bitcoin you
know for example
uh an upcoming budget proposals the
canadian government will be looking for
ways to make up for the financial
deficits that they have experienced over
the past few years largely coming from
the covet 19 pandemic one way they could
potentially propose to help ease this
debt is to fully or partially void
prcge i'm assuming stands for principal
residence capital gains exemption
okay
um
the only reason that the prcge has not
already been attacked is a fear of voter
reaction however that and you know by
the way the
the the federal government currently has
a
majority uh stake in
voting rights right now in canadian
parliament because they've partnered
with the socialist party the ndp so
trudeau's liberals partnered with the
socialist party to basically push any
legislation through
um and of course you know the socialist
party's entire mantra is tax rich and
they're gonna say
what they'll what they'll probably do if
i were to um
take a guess at this so they don't
lose the confidence and the votes of the
um
less wealthy canadian voters is they'll
probably draw a line in the sand
somewhere where they feel like it's only
the wealthy that'll be affected or
mostly affected or they'll help have
some sliding scale system where if the
house is worth over two or three million
then you pay 50 percent if it's under 2
million then it's 25 if it's under a
million then it's 12 or something like
that that's what i suspect they would do
to sort of hold their position but
either way
like you tax a million dollars at 12
that's 120 000 that's not chump change
there's a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of cash for
most people that they should have in
their pockets not stolen from them
anyway the only reason why
this has not already been attacked is
fear of voter reaction however uh
demographics are changing this
calculation many younger voters are
currently not able to get into the
housing market due to the recent extreme
rise in housing prices they have very
little sympathy
for those that would have to pay taxes
on the astronomic price increase of
their home limiting or eliminating
the principal residence capital gains
exemption also affects fewer voters on
day-to-day basis in contrast raising the
hst by the way is a harmonious sales tax
which is 13 whenever you buy anything if
you buy a what they quote is a luxury
vehicle now in canada by the way uh
which could mean
i don't know you have a horse farmer
you're a contractor you need a diesel
dually or something like that that might
cost you 120 150 grand depending on how
you spec it that's now considered a
luxury vehicle anything you buy over a
hundred thousand dollars in canada now
is now subject to a much higher tax rate
after 100 grand
so there's a lot of guys actually in the
last
year before that um law
sorry before that became law january
first of this year that we're rushing to
make sure that they got their
vehicles purchased and any you know
expensive uh
toys if you will anyway um what would
that mean if the principal residence
capital game exception was eliminated so
canadian homeowners could be paying up
to 50 percent combine federal and
provincial rates on their capital gains
from the sale of the primary residence
for example let's say a home was
purchased for 100 grand 20 years ago
which is completely
like average price for most people even
in toronto would have been paying 100
grand for a detached family residence
with a white picket fence that's all you
really needed probably somewhere between
100 to 150 000. i remember my parents
bought a house um
in a suburb when i was in grade 8
for 220 000 and that was considered
mansion at the time it was like
considered expensive
um those houses are now worth easily
three to three and a half million
dollars
in that neighborhood um so that's how
much
residential home prices have moved um
here anyway i know in a lot of parts of
the world world they're moving a lot as
well but you get the idea anyway today
that home sells for 1.1 million this
results in one million dollars in
capital gains with the principal
resident's capital gains exemption the
homeowner will net 1.1 million for their
retirement
uh the sorry if the principal residence
capital gains exemption was eliminated
this would cut their net proceeds to six
hundred thousand canadians can find out
i guess there's a calculator here that
he's inserted
um will principal residents capital
gains exemption under threat is a time
to take action so let's see what his
advice is here because he's got three um
i love his um i love the way that he
breaks down these um options um he's a
ver dude dave where are you man let me
check my emails again um
is he coming or what because he's so
eloquent in the way that he breaks these
down no
okay let's throw this back up
so
um with prison with principal residence
let me just move this over a little bit
try to make it a tiny bit bigger
and
let's fill it up here
boom oh you guys should be able to see
it better
okay
uh
is it time to take action skeptics may
think that imminent elimination of the
principal residence capital gains
exception is unlikely given the
inevitable uproar from older voters i
would agree uh nevertheless even if one
puts the odds at this outcome at 25
prudence would dictate that an outcome
worth preparing to avoid especially if a
strategy avoids the impact of
eliminating the principal residence
capital gains exemption
25 percent still quarter million dollars
in previous blog posts i describe
reacting to potential financial and
other threats to your family wealth and
well-being in the same way that you
would act if living in a wildfire zone
namely that you would engage in fire
prevention acquire fire insurance and
map out a fire escape plan in case you
perceive the threat to be imminent
leaving yourself unprepared in a
situation like this may lead to
detrimental financial repercussions hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you